[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mike heller
sports radio host the mike heller show
1070 of the game in madison wisconsin
kind enough to
stay with us here mike apologize for
that is this personal or is this
business for aaron rodgers well i think
it's personal for aaron rodgers and i
think it's business for the packers and
the two
aren't mixing together very well i i
think that's part of the issue
with the fan base from a rogers
perspective
is that this got personal and this is a
really blue collar fan base so the fact
that it is
personal i think it uh
it brought his status down among the fan
base a little bit that this is
uh this is a feelings issue how did this
start
who started this well i think like peter
king was talking about it started uh
12 months ago packers strapped jordan
love green bait didn't reach out through
brian
guticunce or matt leflore or mark murphy
the team president to aaron rodgers when
they're on the clock to say hey little
heads up
that's when it began but i think the
field kind of heals everything
that was a motivation for rogers i think
he was happy in green bay during the
season
and i also think uh dan that when the
season ended
his agent dave dunn went to green bay
said okay can we dispense with the
jordan love
nonsense and just do this you know
extend the contract
and have the guarantee in place that my
client aaron rodgers is going to be here
and when the packer said no that's not
how we do business which is
another thing that peter king was
talking to you about in the last hour
i think that's when aaron rodgers said
okay then i don't want to be there we're
not going to do business that way then
i don't like brian guticunce i don't
like the way this is operated
and let's move on but doesn't aaron know
that
this happened 16 years ago when he was
selected in the first round with brett
favre did they give brett favre a heads
up that they were taking aaron rodgers
yeah i don't think so and there's a
little revisionist history because
rogers is turned into a first ballot
hall of famer
and a lot of people are dubious as to
what jordan love brings to the table
uh and there wasn't any camp or any
exhibition games or anything of that ill
to work through last year so nobody has
the idea of whether jordan love
will be great dan i really think that
the packers were
doing this to take one more significant
run
up the mountain or one more significant
bite at the apple this year the 2021
season
and then to see where they stood and if
it worked maybe they'd
go longer and if it didn't work if they
were a first round playoff out or if
they
didn't make the playoffs then the
transition out from a cap standpoint
is much more agreeable to green bay side
and the business of football than it is
in any other way this was an open secret
though mike
it's strange i think it was five weeks
ago i i don't even i've lost track of
time where i had a source say it's
laughable to think aaron rodgers will be
there after this upcoming season
and i thought wow okay
and then you find out that the rams
reached out
uh you know this was a while ago before
they were going to go after matthew
stafford
uh the niners you know reach out so it
was sort of
there right in front of us but i'm just
wondering who leaked this
how did this leak could the packers have
leaked this to make
aaron rodgers look petty
sure um you know there's a fair there's
a fair question there about
where the information comes out last
thursday you know
and aaron says on saturday off camera to
tarico that he's really disappointed
that this got out
most people most fans i would say dan
believe
that this didn't happen by accident that
aaron rodgers put this
out there but i could see the little
double secret agent deal where the
packers put it out there because all of
this
has made it easier from a pr standpoint
from a fan standpoint
if they trade him this is all more
tenable from a fan standpoint because
aaron got his feelings hurt and
that that brought him down a little bit
so yeah i suppose it could have come
from green bay i don't think so but i
don't know that we know
and i don't know if shailene woodley
who's uh aaron's fiance is yoko ono
but uh you know does she want to go to
green bay
like i don't know what role anybody
plays here but it just feels like and
peter king
said that at the end of the segment i
did with him he doesn't think aaron
rodgers is there next year so
you know what happens next yeah
it's a i don't know does mclovin do you
know i mean i wore this shirt
in honor of mclovin today i i figured he
had inside info
yes but you know the broken glasses
t-shirt yes mclovin yeah my wife is a
big shayleen woodley fan that's all i
have to share with this
there you go okay thank you well yeah i
think shailene woodley
certainly would be viewed that way
didn't she say on a late night show that
she didn't think she'd marry a guy that
threw balls for a living
so it's i don't think she's a big
football aficionado
so you know women make us sometimes uh
we're in situations where some men will
do things they don't necessarily want to
do
and the reason one of the reasons why i
wanted to have you on is to get the
local fan reaction because i think
nationally it's different than locally i
think nationally
most of us fans or people in the
business say
well the packers brought this on
themselves but
then i started to get a sense of you
know maybe the packer fan is like well
why would you do this on the day of the
draft
uh it feels like you're being petty you
know just prove them wrong and play
again and put up another mvp season and
so yeah there's a there's a disconnect
here it feels like nationally and
locally
dan i thought a week ago today that the
the the situation that he hadn't been
extended hadn't restructured hadn't
moved some money around
the fan base was 70 30
with rogers they were they thought the
organization had mishandled this
when the information comes out you know
thursday through saturday the stuff that
we
that we saw heard and read i think that
flipped
i think it's at best 50 50 right now
and i think the organization looked
really bad a week ago i don't think the
organization looks as bad
from the fan base standpoint today and
and that's really just a
72 hour flip from thursday to sunday
i'll ask you the same question i posed
to peter king
is aaron rodgers the starting
quarterback for the packers week one
ah you know his best opportunity to win
a super bowl
still is in green bay so part of that
question comes back to
where does he sit from a competitive
standpoint maybe it would have been in
san francisco dan
but when that ship sailed i really i
really think this is at an impasse and i
don't think he'll be in green bay
part of this depends on whether he
thinks his best chance to put one more
super bowl trophy in his resume case is
in green bay and i think it is
who's more who's more beloved rogers or
farv
in green bay not close brett favre
had always fit in here even though he
was
uh you know a southern boy he fit in
in wisconsin you know he ate the cheese
he drank the beer probably too much beer
he did he was a wisconsin guy he hunt he
fished
aaron has never been beloved as the
person
now he probably does great things i know
he does in a benevolent way he does
great things
but he's never fully fit in in wisconsin
doesn't drink beer doesn't eat cheese
isn't out at the bars
um farp did all those things right so
i don't think it's close barb is beloved
even with that bad divorce
and rogers has never been loved in the
same way he's a better quarterback i
think fans recognize
that but he's not been loved the same
way i hope jordan love is learning how
to drink beer and eat cheese though
right hey mike uh great to
have have you on thanks for joining us
thanks dan
that's uh mike keller very popular radio
host
in uh madison wisconsin the mike keller
show 1070
the game